[Música]
a mi 13 años
trabajando de albañil con mi papá
provocando la pared
estaba arriba una escalera
cuando abajo
a trabajar a tu hijo
ese momento
sólo comprendí la situación
diego baja muy lentamente la carrera
con cara de cansado avergonzado prendido
mira
y me dice así me decía
buenas cosas que nos vamos a casar
en el camino a casa siempre pasaba un
programa que sería un reconocida
lo cual a mí me da mucha curiosidad
saber lo que se sentía comer en ese
lugar y el sabor que tendría esta pizza
porque nunca vayas
una vez
hijo
cuando nos hallamos
él me ve y me dice algo que todavía
recuerdo y tengo muy presente
me dijo
pie
no importa dónde comes
y qué comes sino con quién gómez
vídeo día era trabajar a la mañana
estudiará la tarde y a la noche o algo
mis amigos
éramos diez amigos entre 13 y 16 años
nos juntábamos ahora
no soñaban con sus médicos veterinarios
el día a día
básicamente estamos pensando en
sobrevivir
y cuando hablo de sobrevivir ahora sólo
la parte de alimentos sobrevivirá de
barrio
no habíamos hecho nada
en mi casa usualmente
comíamos fideos y ahora era nuestra
dieta de casi todo eran
esos diez amigos hoy en día sólo con
cuatro
dos están presos
uno se dedica a la música y otro el
profesor de educación física
y lo voy a contar que fueron que a mí me
cambió la vida
y lo que me hizo entender el mundo
totalmente diferente
un día estábamos con mis amigos en el
potrero
siempre preguntaba nuevas todo un pote
luz y nos sentamos alrededor de ese
hotel husa en círculo
para la persona y nos invita un taller
de circo
soy joven hoy aunque lombo de nuevo
cuando entré a este taller
encontré un mundo totalmente diferente
que no haya visto nunca
lo primero que me sorprendió
que cuando cuando entre la clase todos
los chicos estaban en ronda
y es también expresión
una vez cada uno iba preparado a su
disciplina unos valores a ellos otra
pruebas ya otros los equilibrios
soy yo bueno a donde hoy haré lo más
cercano lo más lo que me parece
[Música]
empecé a regularlos
y vino el profe
y me dijo te voy a llenar malaria
me mostró cómo era la técnica
realmente lo intente mejor y me fui a la
grabación
ese primer esa primera clase
estaban entrenando me dieron
sería la media luna
entonces hacía lo que podía me tiraba de
cabeza del colchón y ya para mí eso era
fantástico
pero cuando
miro a un costado acá estaba de verdad
era en mi costado
stella y me doy cuenta de que hay una
cuerda una barra y un acuerdo
y eso generó muchísima curiosidad le
pregunté a mi profe que era eso y él me
dijo eso sirve para volar
tenían la misma curiosidad
cuando tenía conocer esa pizzería era la
misma curiosidad
el proceso hacer con dos profesores eran
café y sofía
la profesión y me enseña la misma
técnica a ella quiere asentar
cuando lo hizo la profe le salió muy
bien muy sencillo cuando lo intente yo
hice mucha fuerza
me gustó un montón
para aprender una técnica o no tiene que
intentar muchas veces para gastar trazar
trazar intentar un dental intentar hasta
que un día se logra la técnica espero
primero decisión cívico en la primera
clase y logre sentar
pasaron los días empecé a hacer el
primero que llegaba
el primero que estaba parado en el
círculo
redondo que se hacía al principio
el primero que quería hacer de todo hay
primera fila
empecé a conocer más conocimiento sobre
el trapecio avanzado y técnica
empezado milagro mucho más de lo que yo
mismo pensé que podía hacer
entre la formación avanzada en esta
escuela
lo cual es
fue jugar a pensarlo un poco más
profesionalmente
pero yo tenía que pensar en mi economía
y trabajar
los cuales me encontré con los primeros
problemas del sistema
cuando iba a entrevistas de trabajo
porque necesitaba trabajar
iba a consultora de muchos humanos
cuando entregaba bien
que decían que era villa 21-24
entraban a aparecer
[Música]
hice muchísimas entrevistas y no había
pasado ni un filtro
y yo bueno no consigo trabajo me llama
monotributista y me dijo
y me encontré con el segundo problema
del sistema
a la hora de querer hacer del
monotributo me pidieron un documento
que tener una constancia de tu casa la
factura del gas agua
porque no tenemos ese registro
lo cual hay que hacer un trámite de ir a
la policía pedir que dejan
tengo policía en su casa y corrobore de
que uno es de ahí eso puede tardar un
año o dos por quién sabe
a mí me tardado un año
logré tener un tributo
pero me note con el segundo problema
apenas logramos abrir una caja
tenía el mismo problema que cuando
quería ser un atributo
se supone que una caja de ahorros
es universal y cualquiera de nosotros
podría tenerlo muy difícil cuando uno no
tiene un registro en lengua sabor
me pude ser monotributista me empecé a
llegar al arte a trabajar en el circo
azul
y una vez terminada la expansión que
eran de tres años y una vez nos tocó
demostrar en el centro todo lo que
habíamos entrenado todo lo que habíamos
aprendido
cuando llegamos al lugar era un edificio
gigante como en junio
entramos
y le voy a hacer una pregunta
ustedes a los 17 años se han subido un
ascensor antes 26 reales
la primera vez y sobre estudio en asesor
bueno 17 años
cuando entramos al edificio se abre la
sección
y yo quería
entre un canchero
vamos
a ustedes
y otra cosa que me sorprendió que el
asesor una vez el ascensor se abre la
puerta uno entra y espera salir en el
mismo lugar que uno entra bueno estás en
soria atrás
cuándo
y si un ascensor para mí
fue increíble es una experiencia más
maravillosa que me abre la mente
imagínense lo que fue ir a aeropuertos
viajar a otro país colombia y chile
a europa a españa la escuela desesperada
a bélgica y holanda y la tierra
el tiempo a mí me ha demostrado un mundo
totalmente diferente y eso es lo que a
mí me ha servido para crecer
no necesite
qué dinero que me enseñan
y eso es lo que yo me dedico hoy estando
en europa
en un momento entrenando
me puse a pensar hay un mundo
que están viviendo lo que yo he vivido
antes
que tengo yo para avanzar ellos
tengo técnica decir que tengo
entonces volví y hoy en día me dedico
ayudar a ongs o iglesias clubes
enseñándole la técnica de ciencia social
cómo se aprende
involucrando también un poco de
experiencia porque creo que el deporte y
la cultura es fundamental para la
pobreza y que la pobreza necesita una
estructura de inmediato impacto en
mediano impacto y de largo rato y que
esta estructura tiene que adaptar a cada
persona no se pueden crear políticas
generales no tienen que bajar en un
momento a tierra
porque trabajar en el terreno en el bar
del club
es muy importante
para que de ahí empiece esta estructura
que estaba haciendo
y le hace una pregunta a ustedes
todos acá tenemos experiencia
todos acá tenemos conocimientos
se han dedicado una vez ustedes a
compartir sus experiencias y sus
conocimientos a su país a su nación hace
un barrio a su iglesia a su vecino a su
amiga a una persona que lo conoce
a comedores
lo han hecho
yo creo que no hace falta tener
conocimientos universitarios
creo que no hace falta tener
experiencias universitarias para cambiar
la vida de nuestro país y de nuestra
población
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
frank way